I believe this well I've started this
way life were meant to be lived in this
part of the world
I think fishing must have been the first
profession I think this job that I do
gives me this this trail inside you know
and it's just a new adventure every time
I sit out
it's like the moment of anxiety am I
gonna catch I'm gonna catch enough
am I gonna be able to pay the crew am I
gonna need to pay the expenses
when you start working is just yes we
have to do this we have to do this we
need it to me leave this proves us a
monster we need this
as fishermen of course we need to feed
our families she's probably usually and
to be able to breathe enough but you
know have to go further and further out
because I'll try to show a few notes no
longer productive
this is how we've always treated the
seed it was multiple it was unexplored
there were areas where people had never
been before and people just thought it
would produce forever I think it's a
seminal moment in terms of our
relationship with the oceans in our
relationship with the planet the warming
of the oceans has increased the
frequency of extreme weather events we
are the first generation alive that
recognizes that we our species can have
serious adverse impacts on the planet as
a whole there's an economic theory which
has explained where our relationship
with the oceans went wrong it's called
the tragedy of the Commons originally it
was all about too many cows and sheep
grazing on common pasture land but today
it means something different
own the oceans and none of us own the
oceans just in the same way that we
although the air around us and none of
us does it's common property there's
nothing to top each of us individually
using it as we see fit there is no cost
for such but taken on mass all of those
actions have big consequences in fact
they're fueling an economic and
environmental tragedy
[Music]
this is such a big area this is a
shelter and so you're allowed to fish in
all of the Seychelles water apart from
this protected area here yes and there
she's sharing what they'll have another
for this area I'm gonna put this year
when I do yeah
okay that's just not allowed to fish in
oh yeah
[Music]
every nation has arrived to sell access
to their waters and that's of course a
quite a nice amount of money to a poor
country okay so way that's the sedan's
tuna in these areas here take the tuna
shoot in the net here I'll take this
easy you see for me but this this makes
it more easy I guess
with this a bit more easy with it yeah
and you could be more efficient and
catch more fish
[Music]
and how long how many hours is this
process I wish
it's just minutes there's minutes you
know these kind of surround the tuna
with your nets yes and then in minutes
you have your pattern and how many tuna
did you forget yeah liya supported
monthly he thought just to maybe maybe
yeah
[Music]
we are talking about 60% of fish that's
being overfished
so this means that we are putting a
extremely heavy pressure on our marine
resources and of course in the end this
will affect lives of billions of people
and so this is you this is your path
where you went out in January sailing
around the high seas and did you find
much tuna on this journey
yes eighteen days working for this area
there are 15 days work before this
happened and how much did you come back
with how much how much did you catch the
cats this year very playful so and how
much is full a wealth outside and
approach 1800 tons that's a lot of tuna
I went to net a lot yeah
very often we take things for granted
you know because we've got a fish we've
got to see because clean oceans and so
on we think it's gonna be like that
forever
I actually chose to be officially
actually wanted to be professional
professiona transitions
most of the time you actually don't see
this in fishing 40 meters you don't see
what's happening down there
it's just based on your belief that you
do anything right play some faith maybe
[Music]
you have all this adrenaline in your
body in your eyes or ears your nose
everything is always well all those
senses are high gambling was nature will
have a 50/50 chance and this is the fun
this is the fun part of it
[Music]
what it hits and he's just like it's me
or you know it's me or the fish no and
we both he will do his best and I would
do my best I know it
[Music]
the only time that you could actually
say I won't say when you have a fish one
day
[Music]
if you sell fishing licenses to an
overseas vessel that just comes into
your water it doesn't even land they're
not spending money on land they're just
buying a license scooping out huge
amounts of fish taking them away
white plug in something in the bowels
fishing boats
eventually these will find their way
[Music]
Bing is this
yes
intentional
this is more tuna than I have ever seen
in my entire life
yeah many people think that
60 after 70 percent of the fish that we
eat in the EU comes from waters
somewhere outside of the Union so of
course this is it's very very important
that the EU has a kind of a leadership
in these matters Ivory Coast Ghana
because historically our a small boys
weren't too pleased now the small boats
becoming bigger boats like this if we
allow foreign fishing fleets to come in
they'll deplete this resource and we
won't have enough
[Music]
fishermen sometimes they they complain
about Europe and they say Europe has all
these big big
many many people the things that we are
killing whales we are
we produce food that's our business our
business is not going about destroying
the ocean or killing fish is by
definition it is there isn't it well
it's killing fish but I didn't mean you
know just out of the pleasure of it what
we do is our job which is to get food on
the table you know for me it's sad how
shores have been so kind to them when
the industry efficient started in
Seychelles but from the 70s most of them
when they came here there were simple
fishermen looking for good fishing homes
actually the fish don't stand a chance
next just scooping massive amount of
fish out of the water to do this
notation in anything this is a
harvesting
we are a big ocean but when you count
the number of vessels out there and all
with technological capabilities of
outsmarting anything in the ocean it's
just it's it's Kerry this guy
[Music]
in terms of the major threats to the
oceans climate change is probably one of
the most substantial threats that we're
seeing today you have to take into
account climate change risk
the rise in extreme weather events
here we're at the coalface we are at the
tip of the spear where we are exposed to
climate change effects or impacts every
day
[Music]
people travel to the Seychelles for the
beauty of the islands and the beaches
but also for the coral reason for the
ocean it's a beautiful place to visit
and many people come around the world
especially to see the reefs for me the
corals themselves beyond description a
beautiful colors shapes of derm and a
tiny coral lights but on a larger scale
the coral reef has tons of fish there's
so much to see so much to see it's a
really large like interconnected
ecosystem it's not a normal place for a
human to be so it's very easy for humans
to disregard it or you know not really
fully appreciate the complexity and the
beauty of coral reefs or even just the
ocean in itself
[Music]
so how much kind of change you guys
noticed in recent years here so
unfortunately in the Seychelles and a
lot of the western Indian Ocean a lot of
dead you'll be able to see it
[Music]
I think a lot of people don't realize
the effects that we are having on the
ocean because like you say it's not it's
not there all the time you can't see
actually what's happening until you go
down there it's easy to take it for
granted when you can't see the damage
that's actually taking place underneath
the water
it only takes one or two degrees an
increase in the sea sea sea surface
temperature so up to 31 32 and it's
outside the comfort zone of then here in
the Seychelles we witnessed that 1998
mass bleaching event 90% of the corals
died and now just recently again in 2016
and again a similar similar similar
mortality rate and that was only from a
few months March April May the hottest
time of the year it was 31 32 degrees
and then it's created devastation along
the reef
for Alisa facing an unprecedented attack
and huge Swedes of Cory's are dying the
coral reefs are bleaching is everywhere
around the world wherever there are
coral reefs they are under danger
because they face the same issues they
face climate change overfishing
pollution the plastics now at the moment
gained a lot of plastics on coral reefs
so definitely coral reefs are under a
multitude of impacts
a lot of Frankenstein single just like a
broken up with these clothes in the now
just lovely
solo the reefs now becomes degraded and
they turn into those rubble areas
I do that Phil look what you see that
that color on top right thing it's
really hard right I mean you go down and
see these old skeletons in what it used
to look like he thinks how amazing and
beautiful at fit but now as you can see
it's dominated by dead skeleton you get
a real emotional attachment to Horrors
as well when you start to learn about
them and understand them and really see
them every day and how they they they
are pretty much the building blocks of
the whole rest of the ecosystem do you
know what it is that caused this this
bleaching for this reaching is rising
sea temperatures primarily a lot to do
with our human impact on the world
of course it's in no one's interest that
we destroy all of the coral reefs that
we've run out of fish all that sea
levels rise
but the economic theory that explains
this the tragedy of the Commons that
idea about overuse of common land also
tells us that by the time our actions
have consequences it may already be
almost too late it's individual
irrational behavior the cost of having
another cow on the on the common pasture
for the individual it's a net benefit
but for the for the group it can lead to
over grazing the extra fishing trawler
in the high seas individual benefit for
the world overfishing but potential
extinction of some fish thoughts so all
the issues around climate weather it's
the tragedy to Commons as one example
those are market failures we're on the
brink at the moment it you know we have
to take action
urgently otherwise what you know will
will see big areas underwater and that
clearly threatens the future of the
human race does I'd hate to see this
disappear okay this is really as natural
as you could get anywhere in the world
and this is the only place in like this
in the world you know I mean everybody's
itself there's only what Everglades in
the world and that hate to see it
disappear
you got white-tailed deer raccoon
opossum squirrel otter rabbit meat blob
or black bear Panther fish frogs turtles
snakes snails have a big variety of
wildlife you got about 22 hundred
species of plants you know throughout
the Everglades so you have a lot of
ferns a lot of water vegetation then you
have new trynna and vegetation
this is the big attraction ready when it
comes to the other plates the cases yeah
that's the number one thing people come
to see is the alligators you know you've
seen them in movies and commercials
whatever else then they'd like to see
him and he's a native thing it's a lot
better than seeing him in the zoos
[Music]
eventually if it gets to the point that
you're talking about it and half of the
Everglades will disappear because of the
rising sea level what are the
implications what just does not matter
if if half of the Everglades is is that
a lot of your ecosystem it's going to
change your vegetation will change your
wildlife will change this turns into
saltwater this will actually crops would
move into this area and the alligator
would actually just follow the changing
within pest up in freshwater so you
might not see them move around here may
not see them if this area is all you and
that's because this is what the
saltwater saltwater coming in fusion we
come in and be pushing your freshwater
backs
you're gonna lose probably between 1/3
and half of the Everglades if you do
that all this here what you're gonna see
well eventually but where we're at right
now according to the prediction this
will eventually be under saltwater
it's almost like a love-hate
relationship because the same thing that
draws everybody to South Florida and to
Miami Beach is the same thing that we've
got a kind of guard against overtime you
know Miami and Miami Beach have always
had this kind of you know bad boy type
persona so to be in a battle with mother
nature's is not out of character for us
the extreme tides in 2017 were higher
than the extreme tides in 2015 and we're
higher and then extreme tides in 2013
and so from my perspective there's
really no refuting the fact that the sea
levels are getting higher and we need to
adapt to them or we're gonna be left
behind
[Music]
it must be a pretty expensive operation
literally it's be raising a city
we are currently saying that it's about
a 500 million dollar program but when
you look at it in terms of five hundred
million dollars to save what's
approximately thirty billion dollars in
real estate value in Miami Beach I mean
it's a relatively easy decision to make
[Music]
our challenge is as the water levels get
higher and higher it doesn't impact the
quality of a life for the people that
live here and and come to this
[Music]
there's all sorts of ways in which with
explicit the same they're all part of
what some people call the blue economy
but now humankind is pushing the
boundaries even further looking to the
ocean for the solutions to our biggest
problems
well only 10% of the ocean floor is
explored there's many places we've never
been and when we do go to some of these
places we find surprises we know almost
more about the moons and about Mars than
we do our own planet it's a whole new
frontier we're opening up a whole or
potentially opening up a whole new part
of the planet a vast area of the planet
at an area that's remained largely
untouched by human direct human activity
since time immemorial to industrial
mining of the of the seabed
it was back in the 1960s that people
first started talking seriously about
deep seabed mining but since then it's
been a very long and difficult road
we're talking about working at 5,000
meters water depth in very very
challenging circumstances I would say
we're probably closer now than we've
been at any stage in the last 50 years
the technology is there to do it and
there was no downspout
from my perspective is probably no
logical reason to stop us doing the same
we did for all but for other minerals
big equipment down on the seabed yeah it
needs to be happy
if it's cutting because it needs
something to react the reaction force
from the protoid legions worldwide you
just float away why do we need to go
under the water satellite we've got a
growing population around the world
coupled with that and that population
per capita their mineral requirements
they're increasing as countries develop
if we look at our sources on land
most of the easy better deposits have
been mined every smartphone every laptop
every electric car has cobalt and in
this batteries so at the moment the
projected demand for cobalt over the
next four or five years is going to
double or quadruple the supply of cobalt
coming from the conventional sources
we've got 90 percent of the global known
resource lies in the ocean
so this piece of rock here is
cross-section of a boulder which has
been cut by a diamond saw
so these crusts are formed by the
precipitation are settling small
particles over millions of years of iron
and manganese oxide it's attracted lots
of other metals to it like cobalt
tellurium copper nickel and then it
slowly builds up on the seabed so what
we have here we're looking at probably
15 million years worth of accumulation
or crust in this one song
we don't really know what's down there
in terms of ecosystems and species and
ecosystem functioning and all that sort
of things what we do know is that the
deep ocean is a vast reservoir of
biodiversity a pristine environment is
it and are you concerned about coming in
there indestructible so many the seabed
and sensitive it's not so sensitive
we currently strip that's tracks of
equatorial rainforests to get a minerals
would you say that pristine environment
you'd have to say so so if you really
compare that collecting some minerals
off the seabed where you've got really
low species density then which would be
better for the planet the only way that
any country or entity can access any
part of the seabed is by coming to the
International seabed Authority and
requesting a contract from the authority
so it's a question of trusting you with
the tenancy of effectively forty five
forty six percent of the planet in fact
is slightly more it's probably about
fifty four percent of the planet
[Music]
at first I thought I was looking at
corals
and then the structures became bigger
and more intricate and I said to myself
those are not corals at one point then
we found this shimmering water and we
could see that it was it was warm it was
an exciting time because we knew we'd
never nothing like that had ever been
seen before the beauty it's just
incredibly being Trickett structures and
the beauty like a natural Monument when
we came upon these towers and these
structures everything just reminded us
of the lost city
[Music]
these rocks may be similar to the type
of rocks that were on the seafloor in
early Earth
so might give us an idea of processes
that we're taking place in the very
beginning of the earth and give us clues
to the origin of life and it could give
us clues as to the possibility for life
on another planet so this map there's a
topographic map showing the oceanic
ridges and here we have the mid-atlantic
ridge which goes all the way down from
Iceland all the way down into the South
Atlantic and there is some exploration
activity on the mid-atlantic ridge
around about here France Russia and
Poland are exploring in this area the
lost city is an active hydrothermal vent
and it is in the area that has been
allocated to : they've given the
contract to Poland to be able to go and
explore for seabed mining reasons Lost
City is a reminder of how little we know
about our own earth and about how much
there still is to be discovered there is
no suggestion that Poland is necessarily
going to mine the lost city
when these areas get out of the hands of
scientists and you move it to industry
where your goal is a profit or to
exploit something you could you can
destroy something that we haven't yet
fully understood I think the ISA has a
pretty good record of transparency the
meetings of its political bodies or
public meetings held here in Jamaica we
know very little about what happens
inside those meetings and how those
decisions are taken recommendations are
made by a body called the legal and
technical Commission which is a body
that is elected by the countries and is
empowered to review the applications
listen how many people are on the elf at
the moment there are thirty thirty
people ultimately who are deciding the
fate of the seabed in process they are
making recommendations on applications
for exploration contracts have you ever
in the ISS history rejected a license
application no so far no license
application has been rejected so they
all kind of just been ticked and signed
well they are all exploration contracts
so technically under the law of the sea
countries and entities sponsored by
countries who are parties to the law of
the sea have the right to conduct
exploration provided is conducted under
the contract with the authority
according to the authorities rules and
that all the environmental data is
reported to the authority
a lot of people in the mining industry
or in the in the metals business would
probably be looking at the first few
that go out and do it and see how they
do and if they do well I think there
would be difficult to stop a whole bunch
of other companies from piling in into
the business they would be a gold rush I
think it could be
[Music]
years we treated the sea as an economic
gift it was all about extracting value
whether that's trolling for fish
drilling for oil or exploring the seabed
for minerals we now know we've left a
lasting and sometimes damaging footprint
so is it too late to turn the clock back
might we learn how to live with the seas
benefits while repairing the mess we've
left behind
what are people looking at the see as an
opportunity and as a resource how much
resources that when it comes to power
for the world if we were able to develop
every wave and tidal site globally we'd
have enough electricity to generate all
of the power that we need the chatters
real in the world could all come from
the sea absolutely certainly there's
enough power within our oceans to
provide enough electricity for the whole
of society
so this platform is our test center this
is where we put the turbines that we
want to test and see how the components
work how the materials work and it's
been connected to the Scottish grid
since 2008 there's a lot of water
flowing here this is a big that there's
a lot of tide coming through you
basically so when this is lowered into
the tide it will move rotationally in
terms of removing kinetic energy what it
is doing is extracting energy that is
used within the ties to to come go
backwards and forwards
at the moment here in openly we've
already got people who are whose houses
of running off tidal engine a couple of
weeks ago one of the tidal turbines
generate is seven percent of all his
electricity over a week so that's about
2000 people in Orkney we're running just
on tides
personally I think there is a huge risk
that we don't make the most of this
somebody by said you can't burn your way
off the planet you know if we worked our
way through the trees we worked our way
through the cold and the oil and the gas
and we've frankly laid waste to
everything that we're just a tragic
waste
what we're seeing here now is that
people are seeing extracting energy from
the waves and the ties as another
potential income source and it does feel
as though people at last get to the fact
that that's there to be harvested it's
there on our doorstep and if we don't
use it frankly it just splashes against
the cliffs and is gone
[Music]
because we don't know what we going to
get from the sea energy from the oceans
pharmaceuticals this thing could have
the cure for cancer have the cure for
hiv/aids it could have the cure for
mania for Alzheimer's for example is
that the promise on the say to have the
cure to all sorts of diseases that is
the idea that is the hope you know so
there are quite a few drugs that are in
the testing phase so so they're
different phases that the drugs go
through and so there are several
compounds of marine origin that are
going through testing for anti-cancer
properties in particular and so yes we
are we are hopeful and expects the
treatments for cancer could be there
under the wise most definitely
yes what about squirt that's the sea
squirt yeah this is the China city of
Turin our top this is organism there's a
major component it produces and that
compound has anti-cancer activity that's
associated with it you know this is just
natural it's nature's creation but we're
benefiting from nature knows how to do
it best by respecting matters because we
have many different diseases that we're
trying to fight and we also have a
scenario where there is resistance so
there are many antibiotics that used to
work 30 years ago that are not working
today and as a result of that we have to
find new compounds new molecular
structures that can treat these diseases
that compounds and molecules are
combinations that were effective 30
years ago they're not working today
the refreshments program is aimed at
coral restoration and our job is to
restore the degraded reef
we go to healthy reef sites around the
state shells and we try to identify
colonies that we think are resilient
that we break off small small parts
which we then can put into ropes which
hang about eight meters in a nursery
where they're gonna grow to a really
nice size it's where they're healthy and
strong before we transplant them out
onto the reef it literally is like a
garden isn't it yeah yeah so if we take
a small fragment it's able to
continually clone itself and then that
continues to grow and then the tissue
the living tissue on the outside
encompasses that structure so they grow
from the size fragment about five
centimeters to a football-sized about
this be
for the corals themselves it's really
important that we actually clean the
ropes that they are growing so the ropes
are really perfect for algae and other
competitive organisms to grow on
regularly we're down there cleaning the
ropes in between the colonies and also
right up right up close picking off any
barnacles to go there or any sponges big
brushes yep it takes a while a few weeks
to a couple of months but once you put
those fragments on all of that wildlife
starts coming to the nursery itself a
little bit of work to start things off
and it can really start pick start a
nice bit of redevelopment of nature
it was amazing from my perspective to to
be able to go down and to see it today
because it does it kind of does look
like a garden underneath underneath the
waves and see all the life starting to
team around it it's a must make you feel
quite proud to see that to have created
this place where life is now taking hold
yeah I definitely would say we feel
proud
absolutely every time we visit the
nursery and you know we see the colony
the healthy then it's a great feeling
and then to think that when they're
fully sized fully grown the way of them
going to be transplanted cemented on to
the reef and we'll see even increase in
fish population so the whole process
really is really rewarding the oceans
are the common heritage of mankind they
connect us all food trade the air we
breathe we all depend on this resource
that been out of sight out of mind for
so long
but if we all act responsibly fish
responsibly and dispose our waste
responsibly it is not too late to shift
this from tragedy into harmony for a
long time
human beings thought that the ocean was
was just an infinite resource to be
exploited
in recent times we've realized that
there are severe impacts to this
over-exploitation and yet we're still
continuing to to ever exploit the seas
industrial fishing is taking place
everywhere and it's on an unprecedented
level we've never seen this kind of
stuff before in some areas the hoovering
the sea they're vacuuming the sea each
state or individual try to grab as much
resource as it can and everyone should
just take a big step back actually all
the evidence suggests that the oceans
are reaching breaking point in terms of
what we're doing to them today every one
of us lives in the Western well as an
influence on pollution and a lot of our
pollution goes into the atmosphere and
it goes into the oceans
fortunately our ocean has been used as a
big as a big dust bin because again he
just goes into it and it disappears with
the current trajectory that we're on
it's likely that we might lose all our
power reefs from those sites by 2050
every man woman and child on the planet
owns a part of the high seas their
common public good and so we should care
about what happens to those areas partly
because they hold the future life of the
planet this is an opportunity for
humankind to be smart about our
relationship to a part of the planet
that we really haven't yet messed with
we have kind of responsibility to our
children to our children's children to
preserve our earth to preserve our
oceans our oceans are so key to
regulating our climate key to regulating
everything that we need to live we need
to take care of them
[Music]